you're here for the anime Awards right
because you're you're presenting an
award at the anime Awards Crunchyroll
anime Awards how did it go because it's
it's happened and it came out it went
great right yeah uh do you want to do
you want to cover all bases yeah yeah
actually yeah let's run through the
whole thing yeah
do you know what award you're presenting
which will be out by the time this is
already out I think I'm presenting the
last one
oh I don't know if that's I I actually
don't know the exact one they told me it
was the last one I think okay this will
be really awkward if it's not the last
one cut this out if it's not the last
one but that's what they told me but
plans changed yeah are you a big anime
fan in general
I think I might have watched more anime
than you actually but oh is that a
challenge
this year probably right I don't know
about you I will say I talked to him
about one piece okay and he hasn't seen
much one piece it's super long you could
imagine the time
in one piece more than I am I'm sorry I
am okay
he can compete with gone yeah all right
you're the anime guy yeah
not anymore though
what oh right Connor was telling me this
podcast it doesn't talk about anime
actually I'm glad you're on here because
anytime we actually talk about anime is
when we have guests on yeah as an excuse
to talk about anime okay yeah yeah
you're an episode are you generally
unfamiliar with the podcast have you
ever seen any of this I've seen like
this is I've never seen a full episode
but I've seen like clips from it okay
yeah yeah I mean it's long I get it we
talk about poop a lot and um why is that
is that it's just a guy thing yeah
because they're just lights man you
don't poop well I I just don't talk
about I it's just like there's a guy
thing I I thought it was a guy thing you
thought you want to like figure out the
way you do it is different like if you
do something you know what I do like a
lot the toilets with the button I've
never seen until I came to Japan they
have the button that opens it like lifts
up the the seat for you yeah yeah yeah I
feel like I'm gonna go back and just not
be used to it because like now I go to
the bathroom and I'm like Boop and it
just opens and then you can close it
before you flush which I'm too lazy to
do back at home there's also the ones
where if you in some fancy hotels in
Japan you open the bathroom door oh wait
that does that too it's a little creepy
actually it feels like the toilet's
trying to speak to me it's like yeah
it's like come on in yeah there's
there's a few things that are automatic
here in Japan that I've gotten used to
like tax see doors here close
automatically like the test driver will
close the door for you even the regular
like there's the ones that slide right
yeah yeah that makes sense to me I got
in I think on the way here I got like a
Camry or something right that was also
automatic yeah I didn't know Camry's
even had that option is that like
custom-made I think it's a custom thing
yeah you can see the hydraulic thing
yeah my sister drives a Camry and that
was not an option when she bought it so
I don't think that's next time your
sister picks you up you're just gonna be
standing in front of the door it's like
yeah
well yours doesn't open huh like every
time I go back to the US and the UK I'll
I always have this one awkward taxi ride
the first time I come back from Japan I
walk out the taxi and I just walk away
and I don't shut the door yeah and they
have to like call me back
excuse me can you shut the door please I
was like oh yes I'm back uh I'm back in
my home country now yeah living in the
20th century yeah but you know some
toilets also they you know in fancy ones
they'll have the ones that the cover
opens and also the ones where you walk
away and it'll flush for you oh yeah one
does that too but I like the manual
control of it yeah I push the flush
button I will say there's two there's
one for peeing and we're pooping yeah I
don't know how to read Japanese so I've
been pushing both at the same time no
matter what I'm doing and hoping it does
the right thing have you have you
encountered a toilet in a bar where it's
you know it's a male or female but it's
in kanji so no I have not okay okay I
haven't been in any bars or anything
I've just been like so my day has been
um wake up yep uh sneak up to steal some
sandwiches from the fridge that Hassan
usually buys and leaves in there right I
hear him streaming and he usually
doesn't notice because he's he's
streaming yeah and then I get ready and
then we go IRL stream and we're so tired
by like 3 P.M we just we just go home
and sleep and then I wake up at like 3
A.M randomly try to go back to bed yeah
watch some Japanese tick tocks get
really weird ads that I think it's
because they know I'm in Japan right
yeah yeah and Japanese ads are so
strange I don't know what they're trying
to sell me like by the end of it I'm
like I don't know what he was trying to
sell me that guy looked crazy though
Japanese Tick Tock is very horny as well
oh it's so horny a lot of I I haven't
seen that is what do you see on it I
I've when I made a new account the first
10 Scrolls were just women dancing yeah
I was like this is interesting yeah I
was like did you saw I was a male and
she did this that's [__] up it's like
yeah I didn't know that that's exactly
what he wanted yeah how did it know now
I think I've tailored it to be uh a lot
of my videos uh uh Vietnamese people
argue with police in Japan that's used
to be a lot of my Tick Tock seriously so
obscure did you get this as well no I
know it's a problem and no I don't get
it but yeah that needs a thing yeah I've
never seen why Vietnamese people I don't
know why I think the police have like uh
they got something against them are they
speaking Japanese to them like when they
yeah yeah yeah but with a very like uh
Vietnamese accent right it's very like
strong Vietnamese sounds aggressive yeah
I I I'm not sure I don't know exactly
well it's a very tonal language yeah so
yeah Vietnamese so I feel like it's
sometimes very aggressive oh yeah can
you speak Vietnamese or
okay so someone if you can say some food
names like foe yeah you can't really
speak it isn't a pho yes I was trying to
see if anyone corrected yeah
I got my v card yeah yeah I guess I
guess they argue with the police a lot
here I don't know why uh but I'm
southeast Asia I have a lot dude I'll
just be scrolling through and I'll just
be standoff have to stand off of them
just shouting at each other because I
don't know why there's so many it's a
it's a big big problem
specifically Vietnamese is it
specifically Vietnamese okay because
they hire a lot of Labor from that point
oh okay okay all right right yeah
there's loads of videos people screaming
in apartment complexes at like 2 A.M
arguing with each other and someone just
filming it it's really weird suggestions
if you tailor it and you have to do any
of that yeah I guess you have to like
you've just skipped past everything that
is even remotely like I guess sexy and
then the moment you get to someone
fighting you've stop and watch it and
then it'll slowly start figuring out
what you're like oh you're gonna like
you let me out yeah yeah so you have two
evils either sexy Tick Tock or random
Vietnamese people arguing with uh world
star Japan Edition I mean it's
interesting because you never get to see
this side I haven't seen that at all
everyone seems so polite yeah yeah yeah
it's almost too polite I went on the
train a few times yeah and they're just
everyone just does their own thing on
their phones yeah yeah it's like the
quietest train ride in the world yeah
it's a little too quiet like I mean have
you guys been to the Bay like San
Francisco has this thing called the BART
yeah it's not as nice definitely not as
clean it smells like pee and when it
rains it smells like Omega p and if
that's a real thing
so like it's I feel like here it's quiet
everyone does their own thing you can
actually sit in the seats which is which
is nice so well that depends on what
train you'll take yeah sometimes it can
get a bit too busy well there is nowhere
to sit or nowhere I haven't run into
that yet maybe I've gone through you've
been going at non-peak times yeah you
also mentioned this is your first time
ever outside of the U.S yeah yeah it was
crazy to me damn it was crazy it's
definitely crazy it's been a long
journey how was your first I guess
international flight uh it was delayed
by like nine hours which was absolutely
terrible uh I think we got here like
four or five a.m Jesus so that was that
was crazy how's the airport experience
coming into a new country
um it was pretty pretty okay I mean I
mean yeah I feel like you got the best
though because like Japanese immigration
is like yeah
I was like slightly worried and then
like a lot of it's electronic yeah yeah
yeah we filled out this thing on the
phone and then you just scan your code
and then you just you're done in yeah
yeah you got you got the nice version
like during last year especially we had
like 10 steps we needed to go we could
even like get on the plane like yeah
yeah and the regulations were so much
more strict than going out going to
every other country so you actually got
in at a nice time I I've heard I've yeah
I heard that every time you've come back
into the country you have to fill out
this form to prove you have a vaccine uh
passport but I don't understand why I
have to do it every single time like
I've already proved it like multiple
times yeah that's what happened why do I
still have to resubmit it every single
time it's like I'm not gonna like
unvaccinate yeah
like what am I going to do like you know
what I mean yeah
I don't get it why why can I not just
show the same thing every time what I
don't understand right is like is is
especially if you you know if it's
someone who's been traveling in and out
of Japan a lot right like you have the
travel records on your passport yeah so
you can just be like well I imagine
stickers yeah yeah so it's like I got in
back into Japan after I traveled
overseas so obviously I have the vaccine
possible so why can't you just look at
that and they're like oh but we can't
confirm it I'm like there's a literal
physical stamp on my passport that
confirms it